to start the conversation first off I
want to ask you Pearl
what got you into this sort of content
in the first place how did you find
yourself discussing this sort of stuff
oh I started watching Kevin Samuels so I
just started reacting to Red Pill
content
um I was actually kind of triggered by
Kevin Samuels at first but then I just
kept listening to his content and I
realized he was right about a lot of
stuff
um and then I just thought it would be
cool to have a show in London about
relationships London was one of the
first places that I lived where I could
meet someone from Italy Spain
um Nigeria and it's like we could talk
about something that every everyone has
in common which is relationships so
that's how I started it okay because I
remember when I was listening to a few
of the episodes you put out lately you
were doing all different kinds of
content before you're doing reaction
videos you had that video with the girl
that you always talk about where she
called you what was the word
the the British the British
oh
um yeah I've done Street interviews I've
done
um live shows I've done reaction video
I've done like pretty much any type of
content you could name I've probably
done it at some point I also had a tick
tock I almost had a million followers on
Tick Tock with an 80 female well I took
it down yeah they took me down I used to
do relationship content with my
ex-boyfriend I used to I literally have
done Vlogs I've done everything okay but
you feel like now this is going to be
the thing you primarily stick with I
mean it's doing you so well might as
well yeah I mean I'd like to do do more
like one-on-one interviews in the future
um but yeah I mean I love what I do it's
a lot of fun seems like it definitely
seems like it
um so just getting into a little bit of
a little a little bit more of it so
we talk you've been talking a lot about
the controversy now with feminism modern
dating versus the freedom to do whatever
you want with your body and and haven't
put yourself out there and things like
that so you've mentioned on multiple
occasions that you don't care what
people do people are welcome to do as
they please if they want to put their
bodies out no worries but it could hurt
your potential options long term I just
don't like whiners yeah I just feel like
do what you do but don't whine about the
consequences later that's that's my
opinion right pretty fair yeah yeah okay
so what do you think and I just just to
be straight here I happen to be pretty
much on your side across the board on
these things
um but I am a very live and love live
person we'll get into it so
in terms of
in terms of the whole the whole thing
why do you think that can hinder
somebody's long-term relationship why is
it um I just think a lot of guys aren't
going to take a girl seriously if she's
on only
I think most guys will like deal with
you you know they'll deal with you
casually but just from a long-term
perspective I think most guys don't want
the mother of their children on
it's a tough it's a tough what's your
take-out here yeah I mean it's the same
exact thing I mean I'm going to think
that you are for fun only and that
there's no other way that you think
about things that I would want to align
with someone being the mother of my
children going into the future
okay I I to be honest I agree what's
your take I mean as a I I did we're
putting him on the spot over here
with a wife and a newborn child I will
say that I've definitely contemplated
doing things with my wife only because I
know the money do you think she would
have been cool with it though but the
reality is I wouldn't want my wife to do
it
um that's just it's something for me I'm
also you know part of the Jewish faith
and Jewish religion where it definitely
would not be accepted at all yeah it's
super stigmatized I think there's a lot
of things out here in the world whether
it be gambling or
hands of stuff like it could be a lot of
short-term benefit or gain but I think
you know we're in a society now where a
lot of people don't think long term
nobody said we're going to get into this
nobody's thinking long-term they don't
think over the course of several years
to decades you know with my child going
to find this you know my parents you
know they don't think that typically so
that's why I'm interested to hear you
know with a sociology degree kind of
decision process that went through your
mind of how this is going to end up for
you now and then also kind of going into
the future yeah
um okay so I got started
when I was super young not on only fans
like before only fans started so because
I didn't have like a fully developed
brain yet I didn't think long term at
all
um how old were you I was 19. okay 19.
yeah
um but no I'm almost 27 so I can think
about these more long term
and especially with like the family
aspect and relationships it is something
to consider but again at the end of the
day I think it's a bit dehumanizing to
think that there's no other substance to
girls who do own
so that they can't be a mom because a
lot of us are nurturing and want to have
children ourselves so we do bring other
things to the table rather than just
being like a fun little one-night stand
type so let me take this I do hear where
you're coming from and I don't think
anyone on on the panel would say that
you're not human or you don't uh deserve
respect as a person right I respect you
as a person and you can do whatever your
heart desires I also like Ethan and I
don't know how you both grew up into I
imagine you had a pretty traditional
upbringing based on what you've said
about your family
I don't know about umtr but you can tell
us I grew up religious like not crazy
religious with the curls in the whole
thing but I grew up
a religious Jew so in in our world
virgin till marriage that didn't exactly
work out for me but uh you know we have
very Traditional Values if there was a
girl in our community who did that
should be forget about it she'd be
shunned so my my thought process is this
it's perfectly fine
to make certain decisions luckily we
live in America and you have those
freedoms yeah absolutely the reality is
most men are very possessive especially
more of a masculine guy what I think
happens which is a very challenging
issue is a lot of the women who are
doing only fans many of them are
gorgeous women don't get me wrong and
you're a very beautiful girl yourself
thank you it's that most guys who you
would probably want to date
are going to be too possessive to be
okay with that so you end up with more
simply uh feminine guys who are going to
tolerate it but it's not their ideal
you're probably just the best way more
than the best they can get physically to
them you're this incredible opportunity
and they're willing to do whatever it
takes to keep you even though in an
Ideal World they don't want your your
tits and ass out on the internet
so and it's not because men are insecure
it's just that we want what's ours to be
ours not that you're a property We're
Not Gonna We're not gonna we're gonna
let them think that way
because especially if we're providing
for you and we're taking care of you we
want to know that you're ours and you're
not just out there for the rest of the
world it's kind of like a symbol and and
again I think that most women are going
to want a man with those qualities and
I'm not going to speak for all women
because I know a lot of women are like
but I know and there's that experience
and there's that guy that I know because
exceptions are always brought into these
topics I'm sure if we had a panel of
like three uh girls on they would start
bringing all these exceptions into it
because I see that happening on your
show all the time
but exceptions definitely don't make the
rules so yeah I'm curious if you could
go back would you say
honestly I'd be I'd be the same choice I
think I've always
someone who's always been very
comfortable with her sexuality and who I
am as a person and I think in the long
like you know it's been like eight years
almost I've been in this industry so
it's a choice I'm happy with when you
got started with this industry at 19
like what what was that do you can you
share that yeah I was a sugar baby
you're a sugar baby yeah so you went on
websites and then yeah exactly okay yeah
how much okay so in comparison to how
much money that you're making sugaring
versus you care to share kind of the
differences
um I mean like
work
wise only fans is a lot more work for
about the same money like being a sugar
baby was by far easier but at the end of
the day it's about to save money okay
because you don't want that in the
in-person interaction is less work yeah
but you don't like the feeling of their
gnarled fingers across your back exactly
okay yeah I understand it gets very um
emotionally physically mentally draining
right because you can kind of become a
therapist to these people is that why
you're getting the sociology degree
maybe that had some influence yeah
you're getting the college degree to
help with the
non-college activity I get it exactly
does he have a lot of control over you
though like the sugar daddy let you do
whatever you wanted or did they kind of
did he kind of make it uh it varied from
like person to person but I typically go
for people who are more open-minded and
not possessive because I'm not someone
who can be
held back or possessed in any way right
but so but there was guys that did that
like that typically open though when
you're with guys who are kind of less
possessive as you say do they do you
have any typically yeah okay so then I
mean that's kind of what's going to
happen typically is you'll have with
guys that are like that they're going to
be banging other women and you might be
banging another man and it's just kind
of an open thing as many of you know
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible